so
i'm richard this is daniel and we talk
about the circuit breaker pattern
in javascript and it's just saying
before we probably could have done a
better job of titling this because
unless you know what a circuit breaker
pattern is you it might not be that
obvious
but it's essentially a way to isolate
communication between web services in a
distributed system
so go back a little way
yammer started as a pretty standard
rails app
but as we start to scale our project and
add features we found that we hit
scaling problems pretty soon
so he needs to rethink parts of our
architecture
we started by extracting a messaging
service called feedy which we built on
the jvm
so one of the first gaming pros we hit
was with our how he's storing messages
we actually got to over a billion rows
in postgres in our message table
so we clearly need to rethink how we did
this and we
implemented feedy but to represent the
scalable representation
of conversations using just the message
ids
and then the actual content of the
messages was stored in rails still
so whilst that didn't change things that
much
moving this stuff out into a separate
service and a separate data store
allows us to dramatically reduce the
load on our rails app and also reduce
the amount of stuff we need to store in
our postgres
database so feedy worked really well
and as we have continued to scale our
system and add new features we've
essentially followed the same approach
so we now have over 20 services
so things like farvel which is our
upload service
mugshot which resizes images paddy which
is a
like collaborative editor thing
and this has provided us with quite a
few benefits so the most obvious one
probably is
being able to horizontally scale each
service independently so we need to add
capacity
for feedy we can do that really easily
without increasing capacity over the
whole system
um it's also allowed to separate
concerns so
understanding what each service does is
much easier as it's a separate code base
than it would be if it was
part of the like one massive repository
and it's also much easier to deploy
these things so if we make a change to
mugshot we can easily deploy that one
service without having to take the risk
of deploying the entire system
and finally it also improves the fault
tolerance of yammer
so if one service goes down ideally at
least
it shouldn't bring other things down
with it it should be separated
whereas if you have a single app then
that's a single point failure and if
that
goes down then there's not really much
you can do by separating things out into
different services
it's allowed us to degrade gracefully
when things go wrong
so this is a little out of date actually
but it gives you a rough idea of what
our architecture looks like
and also show you some of the problems
with this so whilst
uh building things in a
service-orientated way has given us a
lot of benefits
it dev it does definitely increase the
complexity of the system as a whole
so each service is easier to understand
but that largely just pushes stuff out
into complications with how things
communicate with each other and how
those services are coordinated
maintaining api contracts is also much
more difficult because
you might make a change in one part of
the system and it will have
uh very big profound uh problems in
other parts of the system that you
weren't aware would
would be affected and this also relates
to debugging so
when you get a bug report tracing those
symptoms back to the actual root cause
is far more difficult because
instead of it being due to an isolate
isolated part of the system
it's usually a result of lots of things
interacting together and causing a
problem
and then finally handling failing
dependencies
really needs to be thought of up front
so the fault tolerance
i mentioned on the previous slide
doesn't really come for free you've got
to think about how to
handle the dependencies of each service
when they go down
because if you don't that will also
bring your own service down and that
will potentially cascade through the
rest of the system
so to look at this in a bit more detail
we're going to take a look at our
completey service which is our web
service for providing
autocomplete results so if you pass the
name bob
it will return all of the bobs in your
network
but on a large network that could be
hundreds of names and we don't want to
force our users to search through that
list
so um we use another service called
pranky which
which ranks things in relation to you so
completely uses this
to uh sort its list based on how likely
you are to want to contact that person
and then passes back the most 10 or like
10 or 20 most relevant users
um but with this pattern if pranky goes
down
then if we don't think about this at all
then that's also going to bring down
completing
if it fails quickly with a 500 error we
can at least handle the error
normally and continue on
but if prank is just unavailable then
the request is likely to timeout
which means we'll have to wait for that
to complete before we can pass any
information back to the user
and we also need to do this every time
so every time completely makes a request
to pranky
even if we know that's likely to time
out we still need to make that
call and wait for it to fail before we
can actually continue
um and worse than that if anything
actually relies on completely then this
latency could cause
failures which then start to cascade
through the rest of the system
so one way of dealing with this is the
circuit breaker pattern a circuit
breaker
pattern monitors requests being made
between services
and records any errors that are thrown
and if enough errors are thrown to go
over a specified error threshold
then the circuit breaker is broken at
that point all requests are
short-circuited and don't actually get
passed on to the service
we then allow periodic retries to test
the current health of the system
so we don't want to permanently disable
a feature
for example so in our example the
circuit breaker was sit between
completing and pranking and as long as
these requests are successful
they'll just get passed through as
normal um but if prank key goes down
then it will let a few more requests
through but it will record those as
errors and once enough errors have come
through
it will uh go over the error threshold
and it will open the circuit breaker
so at that point it will short circuit
the requests
and they won't actually get passed on to
pranky this allows completed to fail
fast and not wait for timeouts to
occur and you can actually then specify
fallback which will happen in that case
so in completely sense it will um just
return the unsorted list of results
which obviously isn't as good as
returning more relevant results
but at least means that our application
can continue to function in some way
when there's a failure in part of our
system um it also has some other
benefits over stand there are handling
in
that you can report when a circuit
breaker is opened and then
log that somewhere so you get an idea of
when your system is facing problems
and also prevents you from hammering the
same service when it's already down
which will
make it far more difficult to recover
when there is a problem
so we use histrix on our backend
services which is a java library built
by netflix
there's a few really good blog posts
about how this work and the the
documentation is really great so it's
pretty easy to see what it's doing
um it also has a sister project which
provides the real-time dashboard so this
will
log when any circuit breakers are opened
and you can see that here and monitor
any problems you might have with your
application
um but what about client-side calls
um in our application in our example
sorry
the completed service is only ever
called from the browser
and if completely goes down then we're
going to face the same kind of problems
that we did when pranky went down
we'll have timeouts delaying user
interaction and we won't actually know
that completely has gone down
potentially if it's in a unrecoverable
state
so we really need something to sit
between browser requests and completing
to monitor requests coming through
uh recall error any errors that happen
and then deal with
uh that case when it does um so
we've essentially implemented historics
in the browser or at least a simplified
version of it
and release that on github so daniel's
going to talk a bit more about the
specifics of that
right so our implementation is pretty
similar to what histrix is doing in the
java side of things
what we do is we keep track of the
results of every command that gets
executed through the circuit breaker so
we know the number of
successes failures timeouts and short
circuits
which are commands that failed because
the circuit was open
and we only keep track of these results
for a certain amount of time
which we call the window which in our
example is 10 seconds
we divide the window into buckets in
this case into 10 buckets so
we have each bucket containing one
second of
command executions
what happens is that every second an old
bucket
rolls off the window and the new bucket
rolls in
so we're only keeping track of the last
10 seconds of executions
the values in these buckets determine if
the circuit breaker
is open or closed so what we do is after
every command we calculate the
percentage of failed requests
so we sum up the failures and timeouts
and divided by the total number of
executions
and that gives us the error percentage
if the error percentage
is under a certain threshold which may
be
50 so if the error percentage is under
50
then we let the circuit breaker closed
and commands execute normally but if the
error percentage is
over the threshold then the circuit
breaker will open
and any commands that come after this
one will fail instantly
but the service may recover at some
point so every once in a while
we have to check the status of the
service somehow
what we do is after the circuit breaker
has opened
we let we wait for one full window
so in our example that was 10 seconds so
we wait for 10 seconds
and then we let a single command execute
if the service is still down and the
command fails
then the circuit breaker will remain
open but if the service has recovered
and the the command executes
successfully then
the circuit breaker will become closed
and any commands that come after this
one will execute normally
the api is really straightforward so you
just instantiate a new circuit breaker
for your service
here we have completely breaker and we
pass the necessary configuration
so here we're saying that the length of
the window is 10 seconds
we're dividing that window into ten
buckets we're also saying that the
timeout duration is
three seconds which i'll explain in the
next slide
we're also setting the error threshold
to fifty percent
so when we calculate the error
percentage for a window
if it's over this threshold then the
circuit breaker will open
and we're also setting a volume
threshold
which is the minimum number of commands
that have to execute
before we start calculating stats and
why is this even necessary
well imagine if you instantiate a new
circuit breaker
and the first command that you execute
happens to fail
then you would have a 100 error rate and
the circuit breaker would open
immediately
so you want to avoid that situation and
that's why we have
the volume threshold we wait for in this
example five commands to execute
and then we start calculating the stats
so now we have our circuit breaker and
we want to run commands through it
a command is just a function which
receives a success
and a failure callback and you can do
whatever you need to do
inside that function and then you just
need to notify the circuit breaker of
the result
so here we're calling complete results
which is probably making an
ajax request if the request is
successful we call the success callback
if it fails we call the failure callback
and this is where the timeout comes into
play
if neither the success nor the failure
callbacks
are called after three seconds then we
flag this command as a timeout
so we have our command to run it through
the circuit breaker we just call
breaker.run and we pass the command
we can also pass an optional second
parameter which is the fallback
which only gets executed if the circuit
breaker is open
so if the circuit has broken it skips
the command execution
and invokes the fallback directly in the
fallback you can
call some other service or maybe let the
user know that the system is
in a down state
and after the command is run we update
the statistics
and set the the state of the circuit
breaker to be
open or closed and that's it really it's
pretty simple
all right um so in summary
circuit breakers allow you to fail fast
when there's a problem and degrade
gracefully to other solutions
they can prevent failures cascading
through the rest of your system so you
isolate points of communication to
prevent problems going through to other
services
and they let you discover any problems
early and allow you to more easily
recover when they do
happen and that's it so yeah you have
any questions or
et cetera
pretty cool uh sit beside brian here and
uh he had a question
can you go back to that uh diagram of
services that you have
on your slides yeah this is like about
two years out of day i think but
um is nothing connected to wario because
he's a jerk
um what is wario i think it's only
accessed by the browser
right yeah that's the way it doesn't
appear here
yeah i think i said error yeah i don't
know what that does actually i think
mario never
fails yeah why are they exist in the
browser
sounds about right uh any other
questions
oh we're five minutes late really no no
we're breaking until four i think so
we've got a shitload of time i'm
basically just eating time right now
all right well people have the questions
they can we'll be around so
cool all right thanks guys uh we'll be
back at four
you